Deputy Defense Science Minister, Rather,
has died after feeling
ill on a plane on Saturday.
That's
according to the Ministry of Science
in Higher Education.
The Putin critic
was part of a Russian delegation
returning from a business trip to Cuba,
and the plane
made an emergency
landing in southern Russia,
where doctors unsuccessfully
tried to treat him.
The cause of death isn't known,
but an autopsy is scheduled
for Wednesday.
CNN's Salma
Abdelaziz is following
these developments and joins
us now with the latest.
Salma, tell us what you know.
And also,
I was surprised
that there would be any latitude
for a critic of the Kremlin
within the government in Russia.
Well, throughout this conflict,
there have been moments
where we've heard from
I will give you the example
of state owned energy companies
where Lukoil that's one,
the one that I'm mentioning here
openly criticized
the conflict in Ukraine.
There have been moments, of course,
especially at the beginning
of this conflict,
where there have been voices of dissent.
But the result of that
has been a string of murky deaths.
And this latest death is Peter Franco.
He's a senior
Russian lawmaker
he's the deputy minister of science
and higher education.
What we understand took place,
and this is according to the ministry's
website information
page,
is that he was returning
from a business trip in Cuba.
He fell ill on the plane.
The plane landed in southern Russia
right near the border with Georgia.
He was treated
and according to the ministry's website,
he died.
Now, members of his family
have indicated potentially
that it could have been
a heart condition, a heart issue.
But this is being treated as suspicious
because he was known to have criticized
President Putin,
most recently
to a very prominent
journalist, Roman Super,
who said he spoke to him
just days
before this business trip to Cuba.
He says that in that phone call
he expressed, this lawmaker expressed
serious concerns about his safety
He said that he was afraid for his life.
He said that he was essentially a hostage
of the Kremlin,
that his passport
was taken away,
that he had no control of his movements.
He said he was distressed
and depressed,
that he was taking tranquilizers
and antidepressants.
So painting a very worrying picture here.
I want to pull up this graphic
that shows you
about a dozen different
officials, businessmen,
just since the beginning of last year.
So right around the time of the start
of the invasion of Ukraine,
who have all died or
fell, you
know, met their death
in apparent suicide.
I want to bring you the case
of one of them,
Rafael Magana, He died in September
after falling out of the window
of a hospital.
He was a chairman
for one of these energy companies, Lukoil
and he had expressed
dissent, criticism
of President Putin's war in Ukraine.
Again,
Russia is not claiming responsibility.
It will not claim responsibility.
But this just adds to that
climate of fear, that sense
that there are consequences
if you speak out.
It also wouldn't be the first time
the US or U.K.
intelligence services
have identified
a suspicious death
at the hands of the Kremlin,
which ostensibly could appear
like a heart condition as well.
Some analysts
thank you so much for joining us.